i had i had a breakup with a girl and
she was mad i didn't cry
she was like you're not crying during
this breakup are you crying during that
magic johnson documentary
maybe that should show you how out of
touch with reality she is that she
thinks she's in the same inspiration
category
as the greatest point guard that ever
lived that guy played in the all-star
game with hiv she wouldn't have sex with
me when she had a headache
got one you know
that one's mostly for the fellas but you
know
i love magic johnson you know every
endorsement converse seven up
he never got trojan but he deserved to
get it
if you were on the fence about wearing
protection and you saw magic johnson's
face in the box she'd be like we should
definitely wear a condom there's no
question
this is a commercial you're coming out
of a blackout you wake up next to a very
regrettable one-night stand
you see a little picture of magic's face
in the box you're like oh magic
thanks for the assist
breakups are they're painful breakups
you know when people propose they make
it nice they hide the ring in food
you know they do something fun people
should break up creatively that would
soften it
that's what i want to do hand a girl
broke an iphone she's like sam this
isn't working i say
exactly
you know it's fun i feel like even if
she cried five minutes later she'd be
like it was clever it was good
let me tell you something there's no
better fitness plan on earth than
heartbreak
oh nothing you can do will get you right
like heartbreaking back going so hard
right now for real
and ladies if you're listening to this
keep this in mind if your man is getting
in shape he's breaking up with you
he'll talk he's just holding on to your
ass until he loses 15 pounds so he could
drop your ass
okay that's exactly now fellas that's a
weird thing if a girl gets
fat she love you she loves you that's
comfort
i don't know my girlfriend now she's
like much hotter than me which means
that i have to tell a bunch of little
lies to make sure that she doesn't find
out about that
you know like like we've been dating for
two years and she
still thinks that i laugh like this
definitely
so
it's not great you know what
i don't know i did i dated this one girl
in college for like a year
and uh this is true that relationship
ended
because after a year she left me for one
of the temple university
basketball players that was my school
and um
it was tough you know because like she's
right you know what i mean
it's always hard going through a breakup
when the other person is made just like
the objectively correct decision
and this guy he's like a division one
athlete right so i didn't underestimate
how tall he was gonna be
or how ripped he was gonna be but i
definitely underestimated
how many posters of him there were
around campus
you know a lot of people go through a
breakup not everybody has to see a
10-foot banner of her new boyfriend
going like this
i swear to god there's a billboard of
this guy on campus where he's gripping a
basketball and it just says
it's our time i'm like well i don't know
if it's our time
uh it feels pretty distinctly like your
time right now i'm gonna be
you know the worst part is my roommates
were all huge fans
so they would watch all the games and
i'd have to listen to announcers
on espn talk about this guy and say a
bunch of stuff
i didn't want to hear at all you know
stuff like uh like oh jim
would you just look at the incredible
strengths and stamina of this young
athlete
all right that's about enough of that uh
no thanks
you're like oh steve you don't have to
tell me this guy does nothing but
dominate whatever's in front of him
like oh jimmy could you just imagine
with this kind of raw power
and speed i mean just how hard he [ __ ]
emily it's gotta be
this is perfect
it's the last thing shelley will see
before our retinas begin to smoke
it's a little more light so what
what i can see the bones through my hand
oh my god it is coming from in here
oh shelly good you brought your lamp
yeah i didn't think i needed more
lightning here but
you did so why don't you show me that
dark spot you're concerned with
norm you should have just told me you
didn't want the lamp i can understand
that some people don't like other people
decorating their houses
oh yeah yeah well i i guess i i wanted
you to know that
i like things the way they are and
that's the way it is
well i wouldn't want to force anything
on you do you mind if i use your
bathroom oh yeah sure yeah
yeah don't turn the light on though or
the city loses electricity below 23rd
street
you idiot she didn't mean anything by
the lamp you got me all paranoid over
nothing
come on you got to get out of here come
on beat it
what am i supposed to do at my place all
my lamps are over here
well why don't you use the light in your
refrigerator it's not like that door's
ever closed
bye already yeah take it easy
hey shelly listen man i'm sorry i i was
crazy about all those lamps man don't
worry about it
why don't we just uh relax here and uh
why don't i get a little more romantic
hello little lady
um look norm there's something we need
to talk about
see the thing is i've been thinking
about
where i am and and how things are going
and
i realized i'm getting tired of the city
oh jeez i was afraid you'd get tired of
the city there
it's so dirty don't you think
no i don't or maybe i do you know i'm
not sure
i don't think i want to commit to
whether i think the city's
can't we just live with the city for a
while see how it goes you know
uh well see that's the thing i've got
this job interview in colorado tomorrow
and it's not that i'm not happy it's
just that sometimes i look around me and
i wonder
what's here for me
oh you pose an interesting question
what's here for me it makes me sweat
that's most interesting questions do
well it's
just some stuff to think about yeah um
i've got to go pack
okay bye bye
i can't believe it wiener duck already
was right
what am i gonna do now
all right all right take it easy i'm not
gonna get a cat
two-year breakup built
this one's pretty [ __ ] and convoluted
but i'm going to try to make it brief
met my lady in high school almost five
years ago
our first breakup was around the two and
a half year mark despite being broken up
we still had sex went on dates and did a
bunch of
general relationship [ __ ] yeah you're
two codependent people
you should have walked away uh he goes a
few months went by before we made our
relationship official again
a few weeks after that however i found
out she had been [ __ ] some dude
during the hiatus
now don't put hiatus in quotes because
you broke up
you were on hiatus that was fair um
yeah she she did it uh within the trade
deadline
[Laughter]
i was 18 at the time it took it hard
things got ugly between us for a long
time long story short
we stayed together for a year break up
again [ __ ] around
while apart again and get back together
a few months more
goes by before i find out she's been
[ __ ] another dude
during our second hiatus jesus dude
how many times are you going to go back
for the same movie did you go see police
academy seven
because you wanted to see if the little
mousey girl was gonna go don't move
darren bag for the 50th time did you
clap and laugh like a [ __ ] train seal
come on man you're better than this
anyways as you can guess
things get really bad this time
though we haven't got back together
officially this is [ __ ] [ __ ] i
know he says
we still are in an exclusive
relationship
there's literally a mountain of other
[ __ ] that may be slightly
relevant but who gives a [ __ ] here's
where you come in
i'm [ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] but i
can't bring myself to tell
the girl to kick rocks i guess that
means leave
first love lost our virginity to each
other etc
and thoughts of her being with other
people [ __ ] me up even though she
already has been
i'm a huge push [ __ ] and need some
solid advice on how to put this one to
bed thanks
uh [ __ ] yourself all right um
yeah dude what you need to do is
all right you know what's weird before
you have your first [ __ ] girlfriend
before you've ever been in a [ __ ]
relationship
you have this whole [ __ ] life you
have your life
granted you're probably still living at
home with your parents you got to deal
with their [ __ ]
brian dinner's ready you got to deal
with that [ __ ] right
but generally speaking you have your
[ __ ] life you know you're playing
street hockey you're going out have
drinking beers
you're [ __ ] going to games you're
doing whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
then all of a sudden you get your first
girlfriend right and suddenly i
find how wonderful my life right
um and then all of a sudden your life
just becomes about that
especially if you're codependent and
you're gonna stop doing the other
[ __ ]
and then all of a sudden you [ __ ]
break up and you can't even remember
what the [ __ ] you did
before you met this person right you
feel you feel lost
you feel hopeless you feel worthless you
don't even think life is [ __ ] worth
living
all that is obviously you're gonna miss
this person you gotta remember you gotta
you gotta build your life back up
you gotta you gotta [ __ ]
sit down and be like what the [ __ ] that
i used to enjoy doing
before i met that [ __ ] nightmare with
the vagina
you know what did i used to like to do
and just start doing that [ __ ]
all right get out there be [ __ ]
social and look it's gonna suck
for a good six weeks
after six weeks there'll be enough time
and this is the thing too
don't be talking to her during that six
weeks
all right women have this unbelievable
ability to
sense when you're starting to get your
[ __ ] together after a breakup
and they will call you 1-800 mind [ __ ]
and they will stir your [ __ ] up
and they'll set you a week and a half
behind
all right don't don't [ __ ] do that
all right
you you you walk away like de niro in
heat
that's what you got to do on this one
just [ __ ] walk away it's over
it's done go [ __ ] yourself it's it you
don't have to say that stuff to her but
just it's over
just be like i have to figure out who i
am again
and then that's it sniffle and walk away
and just accept the fact that it's going
to suck for a good six weeks but every
day is going to get a little easier
all right at the end of [ __ ] six
weeks you know
you'll be fine you'll still miss her
every once in a while but don't go back
to that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] misery you
know it's misery
all right you got a man up and this is a
[ __ ] lesson you really have to learn
in life
or you're going to end up staying with
this girl or repeat this [ __ ] process
with somebody else that you shouldn't be
with and one of these days you're going
to knock them up and then your life's
really going to suck
all right so stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's plenty of broads
out there you know that's it
join a gym go to a [ __ ] game go
travel just go do something that doesn't
involve her something that you can
[ __ ] look forward
to all right and there you go and that's
it
i hope that helps you